yes uh hello my name is Triumph the
insult comic dog and I'm very proud to
be Mark Marin's
friend very proud indeed how have you
been you look good I'm feeling erotic
I've been feeling a little neurotic
lately are we good we're good are we
good that's your sketch phrase I love
the
guy no wait a minute you're not Mark Mar
uh no no no I'm not I'm not I'm my name
is Conan con yes yes the guy I carried
on my back for how many
years was at least 10 it was a decade it
was about 10 it was about 10 yeah yeah I
peaked around 2009 uh let me see here
okay let me CH change my six oh come on
give me nine at least give me
n okay 2009 if you average between six
and the wiener Circle sketch it comes
out comes out to 2009 very nice okay
starting over my name is Triumph the
insult comic dog and I'm proud to be
Conan O'Brien's friend and like most of
his friends I'm not real
P you see because everybody pretend no
Conan honestly I'm one of those people I
am one of those people who gets to I've
I've been around I've known this guy for
years I'm one of those people who gets
to proudly say that I knew you at the
very beginning and here I am at what is
clearly the
end no it's great no you got the Pod and
now look at you you're on satellite
radio satellite radio the wave of the
past Serious
XM The Abandoned Mall of the
entertainment
industry
no it all makes total sense it's like
that old saying why get your milk for
free when you could rent the cow for
2199 a month serious subscription yes no
no I kid I kid I kid I I really do K you
kid now Conan O'Brien needs a friend
what a great title I just have to ask
why start the show now instead of in
middle school when it could have made a
difference imagine having friends back
then I know imagine what it would have
no I do love the new show I love you
know the banther and the way you've
managed I am so impressed the way you've
managed to abuse your staff in a very
kind of uh way that the audience thinks
is ironic is just very impressive so
impressive no listen folks he's a
complicated man complicated man the
comedian with a dark side you know
you're like piai the clown and that's
just for how much makeup you have
on
seriously this guy Conan's in the makeup
chair longer than Jim Cary is the
Grinch no I can't I can't you haven't
aged you've grown you've evolved yes you
know back when Conan started guys he
would nervously talk over all his guests
but here it is 30 years later and now he
talks over them with total
confidence I love this man I love this
man Conan gave me a career he gave me a
career back then he helped me grow up he
also helped me through some very hard
times like when I walked in on him naked
in his dressing
room God oh
God red
[Music]
pubes Co like copper well what close
enough yeah it's like staring into the
face of Raggedy Andy
anyway on a happier note
Sona everyone loves Sona the pride of
little Armenia you know you know I think
I might be part Armenian or Pomeranian
either way I have a hairy
back I that's a stereotype terrible that
is an unfair stereotype not all
Armenians have hairy backs there's
Armenian toddlers up to 6 months
no hair let's be honest though let's be
honest though all of us all of us o
Conan so much Conan made me a star Conan
made Sona a star and Conan made Matt
somewhat recognizable in the Glendale
Public
Library seriously he can't walk into
that Library without at least one person
wondering where they know him
from all right honestly honestly that no
offense
love everyone in this room even the
gray-haired guy in the
back you're all I I I I'm so honored to
be here and so honored to be on this
incredible
podcast for me to
[Applause]
PO oh
wow I have to
say this this is going to be a shock to
people but I don't think I've seen you
whenever we've done times we've done it
all the times we've done it I look at
the puppet and what I see is the top of
your curly hair from the very beginning
I would I wouldn't see you so to see you
it was even the same with the clutch
caros I wouldn't see you I would see
just the lips but right now watching
you was kind of like uh Revelation to me
and also seeing what how much I enjoy it
or well how much you well I always knew
how much enjoyed it but from the
giggling from the incessant giggling yes
because uh just that's crazy to me that
I haven't seen you that is so weird yeah
that is fun I'm always everybody else
has now Triumph please you know but to
see you do it I'm always behind you yeah
it kind of was like there's no Santa
Claus
now you've ruined it for the
children